salamualikum' guys if you haven't
watched the show that we did I'm here
with my brother Mohammed hey good job
how you doing that's up and we're we're
in London man look driving on the right
huh that's the right way I know so we
did a program out of the love like we
said and there was a brother look he was
praying he said 10 five times a day he
was fasting he was what he said he was
he was doing the rituals but you could
be doing the rituals but it can be empty
right
you don't you haven't gotten the essence
of it so we try to reach out to him if
you haven't seen that show go to our
channel the D show calm and look for is
NASA Muslims calling them back to
submission said a will of the creator
not the creation Islam and then we got a
response from him
because we answered his questions and
What did he say
I'm trying to remember what he actually
said by he basically made the same
argument as he did before which is that
if there are so many religions then how
could a you know why are you putting
your 1 as the true one and we kind of
already responded to that and look I
don't have a problem as I said before we
don't have as Muslims we have a problem
with people making an argument why it's
just got to be a argument laughs for
example he's gonna get some support from
non-religious people saying okay yeah
you know we agree with you et cetera
just like for example if in a Muslim
community someone says something which
is pro Islam but is nonsensical in a
sense or it's not valid argument they'll
get support as well because are the
other day people want to reaffirm what
they believe but the truth is there's a
true there's a difference between your
subjective experience use subjective
opinion and argument you're trying to
make so it doesn't follow that just
because there are so many different
religions and we're saying one of them
is true that that one is actually true
that one's actually false in your
reasoning so that was a simple reply I
put forward to him he knows more
basically
trying to reach out to him etc and what
I'm trying to say is that I think part
of his message he said that well he's
basically saying everyone to go into
hell we never said everyone's going to
hell that's something we never said in
the video now if you go back to the
video we never made that point because
Quran is clear that oh I couldn't live
in a hotel about our soul and the Koran
says in chapter 17 verse 15 that we were
we weren't going to punish someone until
we sent them the messenger and all the
scholars of the Quran when they were
making tough fear of this particular
verse when they are making exegesis
looking at what this verse means said
that even if someone dies upon disbelief
dies upon polytheism atheism or everyone
but they have not had the message
revealed to them that they're going to
Hellfire that Allah will have to give
them an independent test on the day of
judgment first before they can be
eligible for the Hellfire or punishment
because that wouldn't be fair equality
of run so we're not saying everyone's
going to hell and we're going to heaven
in fact our religion is very clear that
we can't even promise for us for our own
selves or for any other person in heaven
that's something that we believe is in
God's judgment and control but what we
are saying is that obviously if the
message has come to you and you reject
it out of ignorance or arrogance
wherever it may be then that's a
different story altogether because the
Quran also says you know you know
that in the Liholiho through a shockable
ooh am i doing as ethically Masha Allah
does not forgive that shirk is done with
him but he forgives whatever else to
whoever he wants and this is in chapter
4 verse 4 he at the Quran so it's saying
that if you die upon the state then
that's a different story
of course we're priyad presupposing here
that that person has been acquainted
with the message and then rejected so in
a nutshell what I'm trying to say is
there's two things the argument doesn't
make sense point forward and number two
we don't believe in this whole like we
don't believe that
we're the only chosen ones etc are
salvific understanding of religion is
that if you follow the prophets if you
follow Abraham and Moses and Jesus and
Moses and Elijah so long as the final
prophet and you follow the pure
monotheism to believing in one God and
no associating partners with him then
you'll be assured paradise insha'Allah
it's so long as you are sincere and now
that's the best deal you can get in this
life that you're created the one who
created you the one you say you believe
in and everybody else fall in you that
he created you for a purpose everything
around you has a purpose and that's to
submit your will to the creator alone
and not his creation and to do your best
to live by the guidance that he sent
it's simple it's easy and then you get
to Jinnah otherwise you keep following
nos ISM you're gonna go in a way that's
displeasing to your Creator and then
opposite agenda paradise is the Hellfire
my god almighty protect us all from that
here from London with my brother
Mohammed yeah